there are of course those who do not
want us to speak it has to stop
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act the
police will be given more tools to
restore order and where once you have
the freedom to object to think and speak
as you saw fit you now have sensors and
systems of surveillance coercing your
conformity these changes cover all forms
of transactions
including digital assets there were a
myriad of problems which conspired to
corrupt your reason and rob you of your
common sense
fear got the best of you the
consequences are becoming more and more
severe and in your panic you turn to the
now high chancellor
he promised you order he promised you
peace and all he demanded in return was
your silent obedient consent and if
you're still participating
the time to go home
is now fairness justice and freedom are
more than words
they are perspectives
so if you've seen nothing if the crimes
of this government remain unknown to you
but if you see what i see
if you feel as i feel
and if you would seek as i seek and
remember people should not be afraid of
their governments
government should be afraid
[Music]